yeah let's get into this austin powell's
why
it's gold member what's up with that i
don't know i think it's the best austin
powers movie just i don't really like
austin powell you don't like austin
powers
i watch i re-watch gold member again
just because like one of my friends came
out to my house and was like
i feel like watching gold member and i
was like and i was like i haven't seen
that movie in like 10 years but let's
let's do
is that movie still funny now i feel
like it's not funny i think it's still
funny do you think it's funny anymore i
didn't find it funny when it first came
out i'll be honest
yeah yeah i don't know it's uh
it's again it's like that whole like
it's it's the meta thing right it's like
the fact that austin powers as a
character is it's just like james bond
yeah it's just so aware of what he is
that like it's it's the
potty humor poo poo pee pee humor right
it really is it kind of i like that
humor i don't know why i didn't like
this movie
like uh the golden i've seen uh sorry
the austin power series i think i see
all of them and i just thought like yeah
that's all right it's i don't know it's
like for me it's just like
comfort food to just go back to it's
just like it's either that or bruce
almighty in terms of comedy films right
i'm like yeah this is still funny i mean
i i think it's just like the pee pee
hoop
pee pee poop but it was a bit bit too in
your face
yeah when i think of austin powers i
just feel like i i like recall
and discuss really like i think you know
what it is there's so many gross scenes
in that show
you know what it is about gold member in
particular i think it's like the same
concept as like when you see like
you know a troll face comic on twitter
right where it's like it's so
not funny that it's just funny again
it's just ancient music
the second one this is the third one
third one this is the one bastard yeah
this is the last one oh god yeah
and like gold member is also played by
uh mike myers where he's like the
[ __ ] dutch guys like i love gold
like that characters like it's so dumb
that it's like it's funny i just i just
feel like i put it in like the same
category as
scary movie and did you remember scary
movie
see i didn't find scary movies funny at
all i didn't find it funny at all yeah
and it's it's the same
old me love scary movie yeah and then
when i watched it again i was like oh
it's it's it's the same kind of like
this is a parody kind of humor and i
just like i i i
never found that too funny i mean i i
love pee pee poo poo
humor jokes but it was just a bit too in
your face
right right yeah i don't know yeah maybe
i i i swear i probably got a few laughs
out of it here and there but i don't
know maybe
i don't know why i think i'm kind of
just like numb to comedy movies now just
because
the mo like the past five years of
comedy movies have just all been really
[ __ ] mediocre in my life yeah yeah
many good comedy like i'm trying to
think of like the last good comedy movie
and like i genuinely four year old
virgin i genuinely think it might be
golden
like i did ask i did ask can't think of
a comedy movie
that came out after this that was like
nearly as fun pretty sure superbad came
off of this yeah right as a white guy
i'm obliged to say
step brothers even though i don't really
feel that way you should have to say
everybody okay
hot take since we're all doing hot takes
on movies i don't think i i don't think
i've ever laughed at a warfare movie no
i mean there isn't a single will for her
i don't actually think well i don't
actually think step brothers is joking
there's one scene in step brothers that
i was like
15 that move because i think that movie
just came out 15 16. i'm gonna check
will ferrell's entire like filmography
to
to see if to see if i actually because
like steph brothers was like okay i
thought blazer glory was not
funny at all they were just like they
were the most six to seven out of ten
films
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what's his most
okay man anchorman is just like
just driven to the [ __ ] ground now i
don't know i don't know if that's just
like had the boar out
that's pretty good i like alf the
alpha's overrate as [ __ ]
i think i think i think it's fun
the thing that i don't understand about
elf is that like like
it gained like a cult classic following
after like all this time of being
ignored i like talladega nights silent
taking i like i actually like talladega
nights
yeah i'm just looking at this and i'm
just like it's okay everything's
everything's okay yeah like anchorman i
feel like i watched anchorman
past when like it's already it was
already memes to death
um and i feel like the best part of hang
command was steve carell
oh yeah uh
why a lot of late night shows listed as
filmography i don't know um
yeah i guess i just don't find will
ferrell that funny i guess
like that movie is pretty good he's in
that what lego movie oh i like
i like i don't know oh no no no 21 jump
street that was the last great comedy
movie
what's the original 21 jump street no
the new one's really good yeah yeah one
with uh what's his face
ice cube and uh no no no the one we saw
like the really really old one with um
oh [ __ ] what's the 21 jump street
i might be thinking of something else no
[ __ ] the one with the ice cube though
was
okay uh who's the main character in that
uh who's
oh it's channing tatum
oh yeah but like i think jonah hill i
prefer jonah hill in like the more
serious movies though
jenna hill's so good now like it's like
okay as much as i love jim carrey bruce
almighty like all the jim carrey like
classic comedy like mask and
yeah ranch and all that i [ __ ] love
jim carrey and all the serious
yeah seriously like the other one i was
thinking like i'll put bro somebody
there just because it's like the comedy
movie i can go back to it's like classic
but like
if i didn't put a bruce on my didn't put
bruce almighty or any jim carrey comedy
i would have put
uh do you know the number 23. oh yeah
yeah yeah
that's like really like kind of neo noir
like the most serious
you like that one i kind of liked it i
like y'all
i kind of liked it it's like that one or
like eternal sunshine in the spotlight
that was that that was good
that one's good and then another one i
saw was truman shows my favorite jim
carrey movie german show was
such a [ __ ] yeah was good yeah yeah i
don't know something about the number 23
was like it was so
[ __ ] edgy that it just became
entertaining again you know what i mean
we're like it's like it's like a point
of edginess where it's
like it just comes back around wasn't
that like destroyed by critics for like
it was
pretentious yeah
have you seen my three by three it's
pretentious as [ __ ]
joey's like ah yes i don't understand
perfect i think the fact that i put in
the cure kurosawa film goes to show that
i'm pretty
i'm a pretty [ __ ] pretentious movie
creator wow what do you guys think of
while while we're on the topic of comedy
movies
uh seth rogen films how do we feel about
that kind of the same
same thing i feel about willful movies
i'm just like
express he's okay he's like haha he
smokes weird i i i feel like
i feel like if it's not like purely just
seth rogen being a stoner then it's a
pretty funny film
i like seth rogen as a person yeah
you know i like like the stoner actor
seth rogen but like seth rogen in films
i'm just kind of just like
i like his movies you just turn your
brain off and uh it's an easy movie you
know you know yeah
sometimes it's just hard movies to watch
i can't even think of like sometimes you
just want
movies our films are not the kind of
thing i can just put on
oh no no no it's like some he you know
you always get just a film you can watch
yeah
you want to actually you want to know
how [ __ ] pretentious i am as a film
critic
instead of gold member i was going to
put 2001 a space
i would have actually i would have
actually been like actually [ __ ] off
yeah
i actually get the [ __ ] out sorry who
are you trying to please joey
i'm trying to please myself all right